the precursor to acting is you become a
waitress I was a really good waiter I
feel that everyone should wait tables
for at least a year before they go out
into the workforce out of doubt if you
know know how to navigate U eight sets
of six top tables drunk people and you
can do it without writing anything down
so you know what it's like to be treated
like garbage and you can't say a damn
thing back not a thing talk to me long
drive from where life is nothing but a
long drive once you've accomplished that
kind of Rhythm I feel I honestly feel
you can do anything Rhythm timing
navigating personalities it's a SK it's
a life skill and I'm not kidding I think
it's I think it's a really important LIF
skill